I'm sorry when you talk about money  I've always earned more than my man and  I've never made them feel  any different less of a man they've  always paid you know they've always been  the man I've never it's never been a  problem and if you're married you're in  your relationship with someone  you manage the money you build each  other up you know if like you if you was  married now and you want I don't know  nine thousand a year  with you and your wife together working  at it we can build you're not going to  say well you know what let's separate  because we've got a kid you ain't got  enough money and we're gonna we're gonna  come back in another three years when  you've got money yeah you're not gonna  say that  you're gonna work it together